Epictetus says some things are up to you
and other things are not up to you
and then he lists some the things that
are up to you and any list the things
that are not up to you and then it says
you should be concerning yourself with
the first one in not the second one
which is pretty sound advice if
something if there's nothing you can do
about something you might as well ignore
it because what are you gonna do about
it seems like stoicism is kind of
similar to the hot new girl in school
you know that everyone's interested in
she's just arrived here and everyone's
thinking oh she's I want a bit of her
everyone else seems to be interested in
her
so what is it about stoicism that's
giving us this resurgence in the modern
era I'm not seeing waves of books being
written about resurgence of confucianism
taoism you know what is it about
stoicism that's that's made it the hot
new girl yeah that's an interesting
question well of course as far as hot
new girls go those is about twenty four
centuries old she's aging well
[Laughter]
I also want to make a point I actually a
comment on your observation that you
know why so not a lot of other
philosophies I have seen since
especially since these copied bruja
started and it's all messes started I
have seen a lot of articles on other
philosophies including Buddhism Taoism
Confucianism and if we go to the Western
philosophy is also epicureanism but
yours you're right those are the
exceptions did the overwhelming majority
of things that I see are is past wasn't
I think it's for two reasons and I think
they're actually two different reasons
depending on whether we're talking about
other Eastern sorry other western
philosophies or Eastern philosophies
Eastern philosophies are just not very
Western friendly that's one way to put
it
meaning that unless you grow up in and
vice versa of course what's the worst
and philosophies are not eastern
friendly big meaning that if you grow up
with a certain you know language
background culture etc etc
it is less likely that something that a
falsity comes from a very different
language and background is gonna speak
to you for instance when I before I got
into tourism I was actually exploring a
number of possible philosophies of life
and I of course checked out Buddhism
because which is reasonably well you
know known and practiced even in the in
the West although the Western version is
significantly different from the
original ones and it just didn't speak
to me I mean I recognize enjoy
intellectually I recognize that they're
talking we're talking about I
appreciated their ethics etc said but
the language the examples the way of you
know the writings is just didn't click
and then I ran it 50 business oh holy
cow how did I never hear about this guy
before I mean this guy collect
immediately and this is that Isis I
suspect is the same the other way around
if you go west or east of course with
plenty of exceptions I mean how to be a
stoic the first book that I wrote about
was amiss been published in Japan and
Korea and China so it's not like that
there no there's no audience but it
certainly is a fraction compared to
Confucianism or Buddhism and so on and
so forth so I think that's part of the
explanation in terms of Western readings
that you might have in calculus now the
interesting thing is why not Epic Yarn
is more you know this is pretty tough to
practice for one thing I mean out of hot
sand and just so yeah you and a couple
of rags on the side of the road yeah
right it doesn't cost a lot of money for
to practice cynicism that's you know
that's a upside so there is one book
that came out recently on Epicureanism
this was before the pandemics by a
colleague of mine Catherine Wilson
actually here at City University in New
York you know in a book that I co-edited
recently called how to live a good life
there's a chapter on epic Uranus but yes
there's certainly the exception but most
of what you hear about is stores I think
it's for a couple of important reasons
it's not just by chance first of all
because
story seems particularly speaks to
although although one can use it no
matter
the situation no matter what the
personal you know conditions it
definitely speaks to difficult times it
was born in difficult times it was born
during the ulema sztyc period between
the death of Alexander the Great and the
beginning of the Roman Empire that was a
major time of turmoil in the
Mediterranean area things were big
changes that nobody seemed saw coming
and people felt like I didn't have
control over what what the hell was
going on there so that's what that's
that's the environment in which stoicism
was forged and it still speaks today to
that kind of stuff and you know we're
living in that kind of situation
obviously particularly with the kovat
you know in a pandemic but even before I
mean stories machine as resurgence over
the last 20 years or so and even before
and why well you know think about it
over the last century we're going
through two world wars not one alright
we are looking at the possibility of
global climate collapse
we are still when constantly by nuclear
annihilation so it's like you know
there's been a lot of stuff going on
that sort of makes these times pretty
similar to the ones during the ulema
stick good so that's one reason the
other reason is because unlike a lot of
other philosophies including
epicureanism aristotelianism and so on
support Susan actually comes with a lot
of practical advice practical access
active actually access actual exercises
you can do in you know day-to-day
week-to-week
Anna STARTTLS ethics for instance the
new Co McKeon ethics is the poking where
the major book very subtle
put forth is ethics it's very
interesting from the theoretical
perspective but I thought it wasn't
interesting in a living that as a
philosophy of life and so he didn't give
any particular you know actual ground
rules or you know what are you okay what
am I gonna do about this Epicure
Epicurus got a little closer but even he
was not that interested for one thing in
proselytizing it wasn't really finding
that much about you know how to put this
into practice was kind of general advice
one of the things that distinguishes to
us is the fact that there is a lot of
emphasis on the practice I mean if you
don't practice you're not doing anything
and Stoics are very clear about this
Epictetus
says several times in the discourses to
his students like you know you guys are
here just or the theory you have wasting
your time and mine
yeah it's some
it's interesting to see some of the
surface level information that I come
across online on the internet about
different philosophies both ancient and
unone and um you're right some of them
appear to be just thought experiments
from an armchair and then others appear
to be thinking tools to be weaponized oh
yes right yeah so let me give you an
example so I have a close colleague and
friend who is it existential
existentialist philosophers and
existentialism actually has been you
might have seen coming
you know popping up especially now for
instance in the middle of the pandemics
one of the best-selling books is canoes
the plague not surprisingly right
although I have actually read recently
just like a couple days ago that people
are running on your prices are running
out of copies or Marcus Aurelius
meditations and and Senecas writings
yeah that's that's amazed that's it
really amazing now the problem is you
read the exist entry lists and yes as a
general framework that sounds that's
that's interesting there are some things
to really think about and and sort of
them might be helpful in practice but
it's not like existentialist actually
laid out a coherent philosophy of life
to follow in fact they kind of on
purpose refused to do so most of them
actually rejected even the label
existential including Camus so and most
of them wrote novels not philosophical
treatises right so you do get and get
what they're getting at you get the idea
but it's you know you get to be in the
novel and say okay now what how do i how
do i how do I go existential here do I
just start you know drinking a lot of
coffee and and smoking a lot of
cigarettes or is there something else to
it and you know I'm of course teasing to
some extent you might want to talk to my
friends get clear about it shouldn't
should not have different ideas but
nevertheless you know that was one of
the things that that I found not
particular pinning you know were in a
philosophy of your life
if I can understand the point sort of in
an abstract level but then I immediately
wondered okay and now what am I supposed
to do about it then then then seem to be
that seems to be an issue yeah it's the
very fancy app that you've just
downloaded onto your phone that looks
great in sounds wonderful in principle
and for some people it might work but
for you you just you open it up and
you're like I don't understand how any
of this happens so what I want to try
and do I'd love to get you back on and
talk about the history of stoicism how
it came about and as the listeners will
know I went to Athens for my birthday
and I stood in the store pour clay which
is where his stoicism was founded by
Zeno of Citian yes yes see I've been
doing my research massimo doing my
research ready for you flew all the way
to athens on my birthday ready for this
podcast that's an expensive it was a
painful obviously I'd love to get you
back on to do that but what I really
want to do today especially given the
fact that we period of turmoil people
are pivoting within their life there's a
lot of uncertainty people require more
robustness more resilience all that sort
of stuff I want to I want to really try
and get into the nuts and bolts of what
are the principles that underpin
stoicism that people need to understand
to give them the foundational knowledge
and then let's talk about some of these
exercises let's talk about how people
can take these principles of stoicism
and apply them so that hopefully
tomorrow if they come up against a
difficult situation they might be able
to use it a little bit and then that
domain of competence hopefully will grow
and grow and grow and then maybe we
finish off with some some cool book
recommendations certainly some of which
will be will be yours and then some
other reading people want to get stuck
into it so sure why do we start so a
system 101 where do we begin
well let's let's start with a couple of
the basic principles that are
immediately applicable to you know
people's lives so they're two of them
that I think we could start with one is
the four cardinal virtues so the Stoics
recognized four fundamental virtuous
meaning character traits meaning things
that you need to work on in order to
become a better human being and the
notion was that is that you use these
four as kind of almost as a compass to
navigate your life a moral compass to
navigate your life basically everything
you do you should be asking yourself
okay how does that square against the
four cardinal virtues so it's kind of a
checklist right okay check check one
check two check three check for so the
four cardinal virtues are practical
wisdom courage justice in temperance
practical wisdom is the one that I'm
gonna spend a couple minutes on because
it's the one that usually people have
trouble understanding and also it's the
one that you need doesn't roll off your
tongue practical wisdom like whatever
I think the Greek term is actually
phronesis and essentially this is the
knowledge of what is truly good for you
and and what is truly bad for you now we
grew up with certain ideas about what is
good for us and what is not good for us
right those ideas come from society at
large from our parents from our friends
in transport so for instance a good
number of Westerners will think that
what is good for you is you know a good
job you know a good career certain
amount of money health you know a good
relationship some friends you know that
sort of stuff
for the Stoics that's not quite the case
all those things are preferred meaning
that if you have them that's great
but really they're not what is truly
good for you the only thing that is
truly good for you is good judgment is
arriving at a good judgment about
situations why is that well because all
of those are the things that I just
mentioned you may gain or lose at any
time in your life you might gain a new
relationship and it's great and then you
lose it or you might make money and then
you lose it and you might get a job and
then you get fired you know that's what
all that sort of stuff it's not really
under your control it's stuff that
happens and sure you can work on it you
can make it more likely to happen for
sure but ultimately it doesn't really
depend on you and in fact the value of
all those other things really depends on
how you behave within respect to those
things so for instance having money it's
not an unqualified good it is good if
you use the money well but if you don't
if you use your money to you know
corrupt politicians so that you have
your own way and write your own laws for
instance that's not good
then if money is not a good thing so in
other words the notion is that the the
fundamental thing that is good for you
is good judgment because good judgment
is what allows you to use everything
else in the best possible way similarly
or you know as you say conversely the
only really bad thing that for you is
bad judgment okay so just the opposite
of it why well because bad judgment is
gonna make you squander your money you
know lose your relationships lose your
friends lose your job and so on and so
forth so judgment is really only feigned
according to the stoic studies that is
important that is crucial and so the the
first cardinal virtue practical wisdom
basically reminds you constantly that
the only thing you need to work on is
your judgment constantly improve it so
whatever makes you makes refines your
judgment makes you better better it's
good and whatever makes it worse it's
bad that's the first
got it second courage courage is not you
know necessarily physical courage or the
courage rush into battle or anything
like that it's moral courage so it's the
courage to do the right thing right
that's related to the third cardinal
virtue which is justice what is the
right thing to do as far as other people
are concerned that that comes down to
justice you need to treat people just
like fairly as you would like to be
treated essentially right notice the
difference between the first and the
third virtual first virtual practical
wisdom is about what it's good for you
the third one justice is about what it's
good for other people in terms of how
you behave to other people I'm gonna
guess those those two you come into
conflict why look well that's one of the
things that you have to you know to
handle learn to handle and then the
fourth virtue is temperance temperance
is often understood as doing as little
as possible but that's not quite right
temperance means doing things in the
right measure neither too much nor too
little okay so let me give you a
specific example we can see all the for
purchase working simultaneously
because that's the notion that anything
important you're going to do you should
ask yourself well is this practically
wise is it courageous is it just and is
it temperate and if the answer is no to
any of those things then don't do it
oh god my decision-making is going to
take a little bit of time if I'd like
what do I want for breakfast tomorrow
how good are these yeah are these little
pops that actually applies even to
things like breakfast uh-huh roast I
know oh yeah
I don't actually I don't have breakfast
I usually have just the fruit but in
coffee of course yes definitely coffee
coffee is where coffee meets all of the
four criteria yeah absolutely
thank you it's it's essentially I think
coffee it to a stoic would probably be
divine yeah so it's it's it really comes
pretty close now so let's say that you
all work and a co-worker is being
harassed by you by your boss
and then the question is well should you
intervene or not actually should you
take the side of your co-working and
basically tell your boss hey you know
slow down here
well let's apply the for purchase the
first one is as I said practical wisdom
well
practical wisdom I put it in terms I
present in terms of judgment but another
way to present it is in terms of
improving your character okay because
judgment and character goes go well -
you'll go hand in hand essentially if
you have a better and better judgment
and that means your character is
improving and becoming a better person
and vice versa if you have bad judgment
your character is going down the drain
so if you think I'm in terms of
character well is it good for your
character of course it is because you're
doing the right thing by your coworker
that is good for your character that
improves your character if you decide
not to do the right thing that
undermines your own character that
undermines your you know it makes you a
slightly less less good person right so
think of it that why is it is this thing
making me a better person or in service
or a less good person well clearly
intervening makes you a better person so
the first term is yes or is it
courageous it is because we're talking
about your boss so your boss could could
not take might not take it well and you
might retaliate and you might lose your
job or at least get on the wrong side of
the boss so yes it does take courage
what about justice is it their just
thing to do with as far as your
co-worker is concerned yes obviously
because if you were in in the co-workers
situation you would want somebody to
step in and help you out right so it's
your treating him three-three so far
yeah three four three
now what about temperance well so
temperance tells you that you want to do
things in the right measure so that
means you don't want to just mumble
under your breath about something so
that your boss doesn't actually hear it
because that's not enough you haven't
done anything at that point right you
appease your conscience but you haven't
done anything by the same token however
you also don't want to rush to your boss
and punch him on the nose because that
seems like a little bit of an
overreaction given the situation yeah
right yep so temperance tells you that
probably the right thing to do is to
politely and but firmly say something
along the lines of hey you know let's
talk about the situation you know
there's a different size of the story
blah blah whatever this thing is so all
the four virtues
concur sanika says at one point that the
the four virtues are like a concert the
different instruments and they have to
play in unison there has to be no
discordant notes there so all of these
are the four in this case will tell you
yes do it go ahead now more often than
not the virtues will at least one of the
virtues we said yeah no that's not a
good thing to do and therefore you want
to refrain you fat Stoics tend to
refrain a lot from things it's like you
know the famous commercial you know just
just do it yeah it's it's kind of the
opposite just don't just wait stop and
think about it yeah just wait slow down
and think about it because as it turns
out just Socrates who was a major
inspiration for the Stoics used to say
that he that he had a diamond on his
shoulder the human is a demon and
essentially you can think of it as an
externalized version of your conscience
okay and and he was asked so was how
does your demon advises you to do things
and not or not to do things and and
Socrates said most of the times just as
a single wart no don't do it
because if you think about it a lot of
things we get in trouble simply because
we - we rush into doing things that um
upon thinking about is like yeah that
was not a good idea there was not a
there were not a good thing do you think
that the hesitancy or the measured Ness
of not brush li committing to actions is
that why because to be stoic actually
has taken on a what a meaning of its own
right when you say to people in the
modern world that guy over there he's
quite stoic with you know it kind of
means someone who's stiff upper-lip us
Brits would probably be you know fairly
good example stiff upper lip and he's
fairly sort of resilient maybe a little
bit surly
as well you know he's in the corner kind
of scowling scowling at everyone
all right is that why is that why you
yeah I think I think it is and so you
know that's a stereotype and I think
it's inaccurate stereotype but like many
stereotypes they do have already really
exactly there's a kernel truth in fact
the two things that are stereotypical
about the Stoics are the ones that you
just mentioned and then the other one is
that we go around suppressing our
emotions right which which are related
like stiff upper lip and then suppress
your emotions well the reason people say
that got that impression about the
Stoics is because the Stoics are in fact
in the business of enduring things
endurance is a stoic value if there is
nothing you can do about something then
what are you complaining what's the
point of complaining you're just gonna
feel worse you're just gonna make things
worse because not only you cannot
actually address yeah did the specific
problem but now you're also make it
worse in your own mind by as a modern
cognitive behavioral therapist who put
it by catastrophizing it by making into
this gigantic thing that you say oh my
gosh is I can't believe this is
happening like what do you mean you
can't believe it it is happening it's a
fact
in what sense can you not possibly
believe it right so that's one thing and
then did the thing about the bit about
the emotions is it is true that the
story decides don't don't want to
suppress emotions partly because it's a
hopeless thing and you simply cannot
suppress emotions but what we want to do
is to train ourselves to move as far as
possible from what we consider
disruptive emotions such as anger fear
hatred things like that and to mindfully
cultivate what we consider positive
emotions and these include love and joy
and a sense of justice you know a sense
of the right thing to do you know that
that's our stuff so if you turn those
two tendencies with two tools with two
attitudes into a stereotype then you get
stiff upper lip with no emotion kind of
stuff right but I wanted to go back to
the practice so I mentioned earlier on
that that there is a second important
bit of story theory that has immediate
practical application and that is the
so-called dichotomy or control this is a
modern trends if you don't find it in
the ancient stoic texts and it's an
unfortunate term it was introduced by
William Irvine in one of these early
books and stories him a few years ago
and as much as I like Bill I think he
actually did a disservice there because
people get immediately the wrong idea
and when you when you hear the term
economy control so the basic notion is
goes back to a pick taters right at the
beginning of the in Covidien of the
manual daddy that his student arian
broke based on his notes
Epictetus says some things are up to you
and other things are not up to you
and then he lists some the things that
are up to you and then he lists the
things that are not up to you and then
it says you should be concerning
yourself with the first one in not the
second one which is pretty sound advice
if something if there's nothing you can
do about something you might as well
ignore it because what are you gonna do
about it can you um remember any of the
things that he says can you give it a
couple from the yes let's go through
both lists because those are really tell
you a lot both about Stoick practice and
story historic this is this is 2500
years old 2600 it's about two hundred
twenty four hundred twenty four
centuries for twenty two thousand four
hundred years the philosophy Epictetus
was more recently was eroded ended the
so he was active at the end of the first
century beginning of the second century
practically modern yeah particle yeah
cool so you just finished you just
finished it up he mailed it over
yesterday that's right cool okay so some
things are up to us and other things are
not up to us what kinds of things
Epictetus actually makes a list and he
says okay the only things are up to you
are the following judgments you know
explicit judgments endorsed values and
decisions to act or not to act that's
pretty much it
big list it's a pretty short list okay
okay well that makes it easier to
practice if you think about it okay yeah
because you only have to those four
things to concern yourself about so what
does he mean so explicit judgments
meaning the kinds of judgment you
actually endorse you arrived at by
reflection so like you know it's good
for me to have coffee in the morning
that's an explicit judgment that's not
it's not something you do automatically
or instinctively you just say yeah this
is a good thing for me
that's an explicit judgment endorsed
values for instance sexism is bad that's
an endorse value okay that's that's a
that's a you telling yourselves like no
you know what I might have you know
inadvertently engaged in behaviors that
may come across as sexist but I actually
think on reflection that sexist is a bad
thing I think that you know women ought
to be treated as as men that's an
endorse value as opposed to an implicit
value because implicit values yeah
they're more difficult to control you
may be doing certain things you know
behaving a certain way that you don't
actually realize but the explicitly
endorse values those are the ones that
you obviously tell yourself yeah this is
a good thing to do or not a particular
and then third decisions to act or not
to act so for instance it's like I don't
know 2:30 in the afternoon here in New
York the Sun coming in the mine in my
window it's getting warm so you know I
feel like a beer but I'm not gonna act
on it
Messimer we're all for it we're all
friends here just well friends party I'm
not gonna do it okay for one thing for
one thing because I don't actually have
a beer and therefore I would have to go
downstairs we'll have to stop and then
resume you know that's not gonna happen
also I don't know I think I've rather
keep my my mind straight while I'm
talking to you and then I have a beer
later on right actual glass of wine to
be specific that is a decision to act or
not to act
I made an explicit decision again the
emphasis here is unexplained we react
instinctively to situation it's fine you
know somebody throws a ball at you and
you catch it without even thinking about
it that's not an explicit decision to
act or not to act great so in another
term in other words if it is says that
the only things are completely up to you
are the things that you decide to do or
not to do or to endorse or not to
endorse right upon reflection they are
up to you in the specific sense that the
buck stops with you right if you say hey
I think that sexism is actually a good
thing you know because I don't know no
these women can thing I know I don't I
don't buy and somebody says what the
hell you're talking about
well you are responsible for what you're
talking about because this is your
opinion dude you know you can't say oh
well but somebody told me or or I read
somewhere well what it doesn't matter
what somebody told you or what you read
the thing is this is an endorsed opinion
by you the buck stops with you you're
responsible for it now the second part
what is none up to you alright so a
pitiless lists a few things and I mean
let me give you the short list your body
your reputation your wealth and your
relations in other words everything else
now what does he mean as when he says
it's not up to me
those things are not up to you consider
you since we're in the middle of
pandemic consider your body meaning your
health right well of course I can do and
deputies knew perfectly well that of
course you can do things to safeguard
your health right you can eat a good
diet you know you can go to the gym and
exercise regularly you can go to the
doctor
to practice on preventive medicine
although all those things or in the case
of a pandemic you know you can go out
very little you can wear gloves in a
mask you can disinfect your hands when
you can back off all of those things are
obviously things that you can do but
ultimately despite all those things you
may be unlucky and the virus is gonna
get you this that there's no guarantee
that that's not gonna happen you can do
everything exactly right and then the
virus is gonna strike you because these
sites the son of a [ __ ] okay so that
means that elf although you can
influence your health ultimately the Box
doesn't stop with you he starts to
external external events external
factors right and the same exact thing
goes for all the other things that I
mentioned so like real reputation sure
I'm sure you're a good guy in you're a
nice guy and everything but you know all
it takes is a smear campaign against you
on social media and you're done and you
have no no no way to stop that sort of
stuff yeah your your job your career
obviously the best way to have your a
good career is to put you know the right
amount of work into it to do it
seriously etc etc sure but then the
economy goes down the drain
and you lose your job right so that's
another external factor again all of
those things that are not up to you then
that doesn't mean you can't do anything
about them that's that's where that's
why the term can't economy or control is
a little bit funny because people say
well I can't control me but I can
influence that yes you can but the buck
doesn't stop with you it is always going
to be some external factor that is not
under your control that my completed
wing your your plants so what would you
have called it if it wasn't dichotomy of
control have you considered how you
would have termed it yeah I don't have a
good alternate party part of the reason
I was stuck with the tiger control is
because it's catchy and I nobody has
come up with a particular alternative
yeah I notice that it Peters doesn't
call it anything it does it doesn't give
it a name it's one of those it's one of
those things before gravity gravity
didn't have a name but everyone knew
what gravity was exactly so we're stuck
with it that's fine
but so long as we understand what what
we would it what it is we're talking
about yeah now get the practical bit of
advice there for here and if this is
really crucial I mean I apply I've been
practising studies now for like five and
a half years or so give or take and the
economy of control has become second
nature I'll give you an example in just
just a second but it's become second
nature so now when something happens the
first thing the very first thought that
a Christian is okay what can I do here
and what is not under my control
what is it that can wait where's my
action what's actionable and what is not
actionable here that's basically what it
comes down to now when a potato says you
should focus on the first and then take
the rest as it comes develop an attitude
of equanimity toward the outcomes for
instance let's say you're you're going
out for a job interview okay which these
days a lot of people are gonna have to
do once a piece of stuff is over well it
comes natural to us to focus on the
outcome I want the job that's that's
what I'm worried about that's what I
that's what I focus on but that
according to Peter this is exactly the
wrong thing to focus on because actually
getting the job is not up to you
it's up to your boss to whoever is
interviewing you right what idea is on
the other side it depends on your
competition it depends on a bunch of
tanks and it depends on random factors
like maybe the guys you interview and
you got off the wrong foot of the of the
bed this morning and he's not he's in
bad mood you know whatever it is what is
up to you but what is up to you is to
prepare for the interview to put
together the best resume you can to take
the interview seriously to dress
appropriately to address people in the
way that you're expected to all that sir
stuff to focus and not get distracted by
other things during the interview all
those things are up to you but the
notion is that you focus on the things
after you and then you say to yourself
okay but this is life and I know that
sometimes in life you know I'm an adult
I know sometimes you win sometimes you
lose this may be the time that I'm gonna
lose and it's okay I'm okay with that
because it's not my fault if I done
every
that I could after the up to this point
then I don't have myself to blame for
anything
it's the circumstances and guess what if
I don't get to jump today there will be
another interview tomorrow or next week
or next month so on and so forth
so the notion is another way to think
about this is that the notion is to
internalize your goals we tend to
externalize goals we tend to go after
outcomes right oh I want to get married
I want her to say yes I want this job I
want to make money I want all of these
are outcomes and none of them are up to
us only our efforts are up to us so if
you refocus you know internal internally
instead of externally and the advantage
is first of all as you know there is a
pretty tight correlation between the two
the more you actually do a good job
internally the more likely you are to
actually in fact succeed externally the
two are not unrelated but you also gain
peace of mind because you get into any
situation from the start by saying to
yourself okay hopefully you'll come my
way
but it might not and I'm okay with that
can it's really camp of can taking a
philosophy like that lead people to
apathy
it's funny mention of an apathy because
one of the goals of stoic practice is
what the ancients referred to as a
Battaglia which is a Greek word that in
fact is the root of apathy of the world
the English word Appetit but no that's
the meaning is therefore Battaglia was
now apathy as we understand it today the
the root the answer is in the root so a
patella is made of two words a ah the
first a and pitaya a means without okay
and pitaya means negative emotions so to
be apathetic for a stoic doesn't mean
that you don't give a crap about things
it means that you're not disturbed by
negative emotions you don't have anxiety
you don't have fear you don't have I'm
much before I much prefer the athenian
definition of the word yes we need
there's no one there's no modern
equivalent now there are term resilience
isn't it robustness isn't it no we need
we need to make a word for that I think
that's really cool yeah so but now let
me go back to answer your questions so
know the notion is not to you know not
give a damn or so be lay back and all
that sort of stuff
the notion is simply to make what I
would think is an adult consideration
choice and say look I'm gonna do my best
so I'm not gonna be apathetic in the
sense in the modern sense of the word
I'm gonna do my best but I have to
accept that things are not gonna I'm not
a child anymore I have to accept that
things sometimes are not gonna work my
wife my wife and if that happens I'm not
gonna act like a child I'm not gonna
throw a tantrum I'm not gonna get upset
I'm gonna say all right next round
yeah I'm gonna do better next time round
on the hopeful side you've mentioned
there about how you don't get the job
but you are hopeful or you are almost so
I'll get it I'll get the next one
what's the virtue of Hope or the virtue
of positivity toward oncoming events
yeah that's a good question
the stories are not
into what we would today call positive
psychology like oh yeah things are gonna
go well because you have no guarantee
that things are gonna go well
that's that's in fact yeah you better
have this I'm gonna have both edges of
the sword right right but what you do
have is your reason about the human
predicament predicament you're you're
capable of reasoning about things and
you know that luck who destroys actually
personally fired as a dealer right laser
as a goddess Fortuna Orton Fortuna right
and you know by the Fortuna by her own
nature sometimes you know throws things
around them some sometimes you will go
you're white sometimes you won't go your
way and the notion that Seneca
particularly is put forth in several of
these writings is that the way to come
to terms do to to approach situation is
to have Fortuna come to terms with you
you don't control Fortuna for to others
whatever the hell she wants
right but you make her come to terms
with you because you are prepared ahead
of time mind in a mindful fashion and
say alright I know that this is gonna
have a 50/50 chance but if it's not
gonna work this time then by virtue of
that 50-50 chance that means that next
time I'm going to have also a 50/50
chance and one of these days are going
to get it so it's not really optimism as
much as a realistic understanding of
what the situation is um you may be
familiar with this but Alain de Botton
from the scales of life he has a
wonderful bear I've seen him give the
same talk twice now on his his book in
emotional education and you may be able
to Pat out this story that I'm about to
tell a little but I think he said that
in ancient Athens the people that were
homeless that were the beggars on the
street that were potentially sort of
disease and stuff like that they were
referred to as unfortunates I think that
that was the etiology of it right was
the Greek word yeah unformed in that I
think it's because okay so yeah they
were referred to as unfortunate and he
rolls the clock forward and we got
ourselves into the 21st century what's
the equivalent
new people that are listening
couple of seconds what's the equivalent
of an unfortunate in today's vernacular
it's a loser that's what they call but
the people that don't that it's a loser
and what happened what Alan argues and I
think I believe that I agree with is
that in a meritocracy which is what we
say that we have no equal chance equal
ability all that's right and not equal
ability equal opportunity chosen be
family in a in a meritocracy if the
people who succeed are worthy of their
successes that also means that the
people who fail a worthy of their
failures as that shift from the
unfortunate to the loser I think is a
real a very easy way to see why society
may be less empathetic toward the people
who don't have the haves and the
have-nots yeah and it is an incredibly
unfortunate shift because I think that
the ancient Greeks in general and the
Stoics in particular were right about
this that it is a matter of fortune now
meaning not that that the outcome has
nothing to do with your with your
efforts of course it does no question
about it and there are some people who
are responsible for their own damn
downfall because they do make bad
decisions you know that this is a fact
of human life but those people include
very rich people are very powerful
people I mean the history is replete
with you know powerful and rich people
who make really stupid or really bad
decisions and then you know and that's
the damn downfall so it's not a question
of abdicating responsibility it's a
quite a straighter question to
understand that that external events
will hit people even the best people
even the people that make the best
effort they will be hit because Fortuna
doesn't care Fortuna is kind of a you
know it's a it's a random the random
thing
Fortuna can be a bit of a [ __ ]
sometimes country well you know but she
could also be very good yeah so I was
for instance I was reading us so I I
just um I'm just about to launch a
zooom based book club that how cool yeah
where can people find out more about
that if they're interested go to my
meetup site which is the store Nova so
go to meetup.com and and search for
store Nova yep and you'll find it or
actually search naturally even better
search for philosophy book club and
you'll find it it's even easier because
it's not just about sources but the
first book that we're reading that the
first meeting is scheduled for May 11th
is the consolation of philosophy by beau
Asia's not to be confused with the
consolations of philosophy plural by the
bottom right and wishes was a one of the
last Romans basically he was living in
ready and Roman Empire it was a
philosopher he was also an advisor to
the king and he was doing very well for
most of his life his sons were doing
well his family was doing well blah blah
blah and then at some point he was doing
so well that some envious people started
putting rumors about him and one of
these rumors arrived to the Kings year
and as a result he was accused of
treason and condemned to death I'm and
he was executed in fact now when he was
in prison in Rome he wrote the book the
consolation of philosophy and imagines
in this book that philosophy philosophy
comes in and basically tries to cheer
him up right and and the one of the
first things a lady for so it's a
dialogue between him and some of it some
of it is poetry and someone this prose
it's just really a wonderful book and
Lady philosophy but one of the first
things that she does like so you forgot
you urate you're upset about Fortuna
right you think the Fortuna treated you
unfairly and and and he says yeah of
course give me a fail me I mean Here I
am condemned to death I'm about to be
beheaded like what the hell
and then Pilate says but so you forget
all of the other good stuff the fruit
then I gave you right
so for most of your life you were much
more lucky than most people in this in
this country your sons are still doing
very well your wife is still doing very
well your family fortune is untouched
you're doing much better even condemned
being condemned to death then most
people around you so it's like
did you not know that fortuna works this
way that sometimes you gives and that
she takes
somehow you got convinced that you among
mortals were the only one there was no
only gonna gap and never never gonna you
know be taken from it's like come on
it's like you she's she's shining him
for essentially behaving like a child
forgetting miss philosophical training
and and expecting the impossible
expecting the Santa Claus keeps coming
and coming and coming it's like you know
sometimes it's just poles so let's get
some exercises let's get some ways that
people can apply some of the stuff we've
spoken about and then some other
principles as well so you've already
touched on one of them which is when
something happens when anything happens
try and work out whether it is or with
is not within your control right yes
that's right in fact with my friend and
colleague Gregory Lopez we have written
a whole book of Stoick exercises is
called a handbook for for new study I
think in UK the title is living like a
stoic or something like that it's I
don't know for what reason they change
the title it's confusing but but anyway
we actually put together a entire
curriculum for with 52 different
exercises that people can sample and see
what works for them and what doesn't
work for them why don't you give us why
don't you give us your favorite five you
give us your top five something like
that yeah something like that so one of
them is the one that we've been talking
about and the economic control exercises
can actually be done in the in the
following way let's say that you are
about to do something the outcome which
is in doubt Lots such as the job
interview that was talking about before
well the way you do the exercise is that
in the days before the actual event or
the night before whenever whatever it's
convenient for you whatever you think it
works for you you literally sit down and
write down you took a piece of paper or
spreadsheet and you get two columns
things under my control things not under
my control and then you start breaking
down the situation and listening to
yourself the kind of stuff that is up to
you and the kind of stuff that is not up
to you and then the notion being that
then on the next several days you use
before the interview you use that list
to remind yourself you've got
do it and remind yourself to focus on
the first column and and prepare
yourself about the second column so
that's one exercise another one of my
favorite exercises is the sometimes it's
referred to as the even in meditation
sometimes referred to as philosophical
journaling because you can do it as an
actual journalist writing running in a
journal that's the way I do it but it
doesn't have to be a journal this is an
exercise that comes comes from several
stores in fact Epictetus mentions
explicitly this approaching the
enchiridion and Seneca does it at the
end of on Inger and you can read the
entire meditations on marcus aurelius
essentially as a drooling exercise
because it was it was his own
philosophical diary that's what it was
now the idea here is not to write the
meditations because not well now every
not everybody is marker Makris rayless
and you know we're not that good writers
and this is certainly not for
publication but the notion is I tend to
do it I try to do it every night but you
can do it at least several times a week
it only takes a few minutes you sit down
take a moment before you go to bed don't
do any bed otherwise you fall asleep
before you go to bed pick a moment where
it's quiet and you can concentrate for a
few minutes and write down some thoughts
about the major things that happened
during the day or even a single major
thing that happened during the day it
doesn't have to be comprehensive and
about that thing ask yourself three
questions number one what did I do wrong
number two what did i do right number
three what could I do different yeah
differently if this a similar situation
arises again but what's the point the
first question what is it wrong the
notion is not to you know beat yourself
up and say uh I should have done this I
should because the past is another one
of those things it's not up to you it's
outside of your control you can't change
it you can't go back and redo the thing
right no matter how many times you
actually rerun the thing in your what
happened in your mind you cannot change
in fact the starts would say that's a
waste of emotional energy the
the only gonna feel bad about it that's
it instead however what you do want to
do is to learn from your from your
mistakes so you wanna have you want to
write down it's like okay this is what I
did wrong because you want to pay
attention to it and then Seneca says
immediately forgive yourself you have
the power to forgive yourself so write
it down and then say okay that's done
out I learned my lesson I hope not to do
it again but that's it
second what did they do right well part
of the reason for doing that is because
pat yourself on the back if you do
something right great um you know this
is this is progress you're making you go
in the right direction but also because
now you have two points of reference
what you did wrong what you did right
and the notion is that day by day you
want to move as far away from the first
one and it's close as possible to the
second one so you want to do fewer and
fewer wrong things and more and more
right things right and so if you keep it
in mind as to two posts essentially two
reference points that's helpful the
third thing is you know what could I do
it done better
why engage into the I pathetical because
you know we all like to think of our
lives is extremely varied and
unpredictable and all sorts of
interesting things is gonna happen but
usually that's not the case
we kind of lived the same life every day
you know you get up you go to the world
actually during long term we live that
we live the yeah that same life every
day better yeah especially now but even
outside right now so you go to work you
see the same people you do the same two
kind of things then you get back home
you see the same people using the same
kind of things and you go out in the
weekend and you see friends those are
the same people do the same kind of
things of course there is variation of
course sometimes you do something truly
novel but mostly we tend to be routine
kind of people you know we do the same
thing over which means that it pays off
to pay attention when you actually did
something wrong because you can gonna
start saying okay well this won't be the
more care very well but I know this kind
of situation is gonna happen again
or something very similar is gonna
happen again so let me think I helped
the next time is something like this
happen what what am I gonna do
and so I can give a small example of how
this works
this is a trivial thing this is the
thing that happened years ago
I was walking down and you know lower
Manhattan I was weird friend and I was
obviously not looking very carefully
where I was going so this other woman
who was also not looking where she was
going so it bumps into me and she had a
large Starbucks coffee penny and it's
when it over the place now nothing
terrible happened we're both surprised
and we both said you know sorry and then
but we both then kept moving right and
then I thought about it later I said you
know I think that was mostly my fault
I was paying less attention than she was
so it wouldn't be nice to actually offer
her to pay from the coffee that's it's a
small thing it's like a couple of but
well it's Starbucks so it's more than a
couple bucks but anyway um it's not that
much and it would have been a nice
gesture to do the moment was past who
knows where that woman was so that's
done but that kind of situation can
happen again
you can't bump into people and if the
next time you're preparing you say you
know something and that happens again
next time this is what's going what's
gonna happen this is what I'm gonna do
then you're prepared and Seneca tells
you over and over a prepare mind feels
better with situations then an
unprepared mind so that's the point of
the exercise the preparing for things by
using existing experiences I've been
discussing this an awful awful lot
recently and um the analogy that I
always use is if I told you Massimo that
you were gonna fall into some quicksand
a week from now right now at seven
three minutes to 8:00 p.m. on a
Wednesday night or whatever it is and I
said you got a week to prepare and you
spent the next week you go online and
research strategies to get out of
quicksand what's the most efficient way
my even Burress dress slightly
differently ready for the quicksand and
then you'd be counting down on you the
difference between that and me just
pushing you into some quicksand now and
saying good luck know the difference
it's huge yeah absolutely because we
really really struggle to make rational
decisions when we're in the moment and
the listeners will be familiar Michael
malice said to any of his fans who were
struggling he's also living in Brooklyn
in New York and he said to any of his
fans on his show he's got these hundreds
of thousands of listeners anyone who's
suffering with depression or suicidal
ideation when you're in your best mind
write yourself a letter write a letter
to you when you are in the depths of
feeling down and feeling depressed and
tell yourself what you're gonna do tell
yourself to bring a friend tell yourself
to go for a walk tell yourself to get a
glass of water and do the things that
make you feel good because that person
then is you at your best that your most
rational with all of your faculties
intact whereas you when you're feeling
depressed when you're feeling down
that's you in quicksand and it's very
difficult to strategize whilst you're
also executing and there's a lot of
evidence from modern psychology by the
way that is this dissent this thing
actually does work some of your
listeners might be familiar with Daniel
Kahneman
best-selling book thinking faster slow
now Cattleman's research clearly shows
that we have these two metaphorical
system they're not actually anatomical
systems but these are metaphorical
systems in the brain one that is for
very quick thinking in the moment the
reaction you know you're actually not
even not even not thinking in the sense
of you know sort of reflecting on things
it's just immediate it's like that on
this neck snap that's the fast one and
then we have these slower you know more
deliberate more you know cognate
cognitive approach to things and the
idea is instead of stories dismiss as
much as it is possible as much as it is
feasible switch from system one to suah
system two
bow down sometimes it's not possible
right I mean if I may say if some
somebody's gonna run out run after you
and you know with with a gun and you
never happened before
and you probably will never happen again
you're gonna do whatever system one says
right if it is dock your dock if it is
scream you scream whatever whatever it
is that's you have to rely on your
instincts and good luck to you right but
if you can and you know a lot of
situated on we don't actually live in
war zones we don't live in you know in
the Savannah where the lion can be
coming at any minute we tend to live in
fairly structured societies where things
happen in a slow slower pace so we do
have the time to slow down and can
engage system to and say okay what is
the best thing to do by the way even
about the thing that I just said which
is that some situations you just can't
avoid engaging system one
Epictetus obviously did not know about
system 1 or system 2 but he had a pretty
good idea that some time to react in the
moment and sometimes we actually have
ability to think right one of the
reasons he kept telling me students that
they have to practice ahead of time
regularly every day right that remind be
mindful you do these exercises regularly
it's precisely because he wanted to make
their decision-making automatic
all right so when I set for instance if
you remember a few minutes ago I said
that economy of control is now automatic
for me right so initially when I started
studying studying stoicism I had to
remind myself and slow down and say wait
a minute what is under your control what
is not in your control all right let me
make the list right I actually had to go
and make the list but after you start
doing it on a regular basis then it
becomes Hermione's a list anymore it's
immediately when a situation comes up it
has shifted from system - to system one
it's that it's an experience that feels
a lot like learning to drive a car so if
you remember but when you start driving
a car even though I live in the United
States actually learning Italy so I had
a sixth if this kind of stuff an actual
a real car in a proper car yeah probably
and you know when you start learning
it's like oh my gosh that I have to all
these things to think about it is that
it's the clutch and then it's the brake
and then it's like it's steering wheel
and I'd look at the at the people
outside and listen to the Caddy's gaming
stuff it's like whoa all of that takes a
lot of slow deliberate thinking and that
means you're not a good driver initially
right because precisely because very
lazy think yeah right but then you start
doing it and the more you do the more
become automatic and so now you can you
know can you can gingerly ship do it
while you're singing singing to the
music on the radio I'm thinking about
the other stuff yeah isn't it isn't it
interesting that you you are
deprogramming system-1 you're creating
what Cory Allen would refer to as the
mindfulness gap which is what I love
it's that it's that break in between
stimulus and response so you're deep
probe deep programming system one then
allowing system two to come in then
reprogramming system two and habit izing
it or systematizing it sufficiently
frequently to then reintegrate the
upgraded version of system one the
beauty of that I'm reading a lot of
evolutionary psychology at the moment a
lot of Robert Wright and others yeah
yeah um oh he's a good friend you know
he's a phenomenal man he's that guy that
guy the moral animal everyone that's
listening psycho God shut up of a
[ __ ] moral animal but until
everyone's ready until everyone's ready
I'm gonna keep talking about it so go do
it and uh yeah because we are energy
conservation machines you know our
evolutionary heritage is to is to expend
as little energy as possible this is the
literally the double-edged sword of
habits right it's the fact that you want
to automate as much as you can but
unfortunately that means that you went
bad bad habits as easily as good habits
and sometimes even easier so you've got
the you've got the initial cost right to
pay at the very start but it's inspiring
to hear that someone like you has been
able to take something which sounds
awfully labored right it's driving the
car it's I gotta get in and the user
left-hand and depress the clutch and
then use it a little bit and find the
biting point and all that stuff and then
now you
managed to instill this you've
instantiate it to the point where as you
say it is that and and mercifully for me
I've seen an equivalent happen with my
mindfulness practice so I've been doing
a particular practice from Shinzon young
which has focused on rest and what
happens is when you realize that you've
become lost in thought you label the
thought as either see hear or feel so
visual imagery auditory noise within the
head or somatic sensation label it is
that and then let it go and return to
whatever it is that you're doing and
upon having sat on the cushion doing
that that one area of that one practice
within this one school probably maybe
150 hours now not much more so not a
huge amount of time certainly not by
meditation terms but not nothing and
that's been maybe a year year and a half
and now I find myself doing stuff I'll
be walking down the street now I'll
realize I'll be like you're thinking
about work later on just enjoy the walk
focus on rest and you just label it and
let it go and it's um there's a degree
of satisfaction that again we don't
think we actually have a word for but
there is a degree of satisfaction to do
with reprogramming your own mind to be
able to do that and it is there is
there's not many there's not many great
feelings than that I don't think then
transcending your own nature you're
right and this is something that that
several traditions have hit on the
Buddhists have invented techniques to do
precisely these kind of things to sort
of to be more mindful in then automated
automating that that mindfulness the
stories re startle the story kept saying
that the way to improve your character
is by practice it's just the same way in
which you get to Carnegie Hall practice
practice practice
I wanted sorry I know you're gonna keep
going that quote about
EXO we are what we repeatedly do
excellence therefore is not an act but a
habit what was that
Aristotle I believe it is a result I
believe it is in the Nicomachean ethics
but I need to check that okay because
I've seen equal number of blog posts
discrediting it and saying it's someone
else as saying that it was him
no it's I'm pretty sure it is very
subtle but it may not be the exact word
that's fine that's fine I've got it I've
got it from the equivalent of the
horse's mouth so I'm you know I mean I'm
happy so let me give you an example of
what what what I'm talking about um as
you know we only lock down here with my
wife we are gonna reach day 40 this
coming Friday yeah yeah it's interesting
situation okay now a couple weeks ago in
the middle of this thing we open the
refrigerator and the refrigerator is not
working anymore like mmm not a good
thing bad timing right it's bad timing
for one thing because of course that
literally means you cannot store you
know reasonable quantity of food and
also our building has a policy against
delivery of furniture for security
reasons during this period while in
while in lockdown new furniture new
appliances cannot be delivered and the
story okay so now normally and by
normally I mean you know like several
years ago I would have gotten upset then
I would say oh god damn it it's like you
know this thing is like not only we got
a pandemic but now and we can't eat it's
like Oh what are we gonna do bla bla bla
instead the very first thing you know we
looked at each other because my wife
also is pretty aware of historic
principle so we look at each other said
okay what's actionable here well it's
under our control
well the first thing is to redo the
shopping list moving away from stuff
that needs a refrigeration to you know
Drive foods like pasta canned foods like
beans and things like number one that
was the first the very first thing
number two let's call the landlady and
see where she says she might have some
ideas this may
happened before for all I know so we
call and she says well I'm going to
replace the refrigerator but I can't do
it now for the reasons that I just
explained you know the camp you deliver
appliances can't be delivered but she
said I checked with the building and it
turns out that small refrigerators like
in a dorm kind level refrigerators can
be delivered so I just ordered one for
you and it's gonna come in the next
couple of days that was it problem
solved I mean I still have the small
refrigerator here because the big me is
still not working
yeah and so now we switch to a diet of
you know that includes some fresh fruit
and yeah water and dry stuff and
everything and there was no getting
upsetting upset there was no you know
any no emotional response and whatsoever
is like but just look at a challenge
there okay so but this is an interesting
challenge let's see what we can do about
it
that's another trick by the way that the
storage deployed deployed and it turns
out is confirmed by modern psychology
it's called the framing effect so the
framing effect in psychology consistent
in the in the phenomenon that if you
present the same exact information to
people but in two different ways they
will react differently depending on how
the information is presented for
instance you go to the doctor because
you're worried about something and the
doctor says all right you got a 90
percent chances of making through this
or he says all right you got a 10%
chances of dying this now you with that
doctor right now the fact notice that
the faction information is exactly the
same 90% survival rate is exactly the
same as 10% death rate there's no
there's no difference at all but as you
just noticed people will react
differently right depending on where you
put it this one way or the other
now the framing effect has been used by
Stoics for more than 2,000 years to look
at the same situation in a more
productive way Marcus here it is writes
in the meditation that if we find an
obstacle instead of banging your head
against the obstacle the obstacle is
unbreakable
you need to find a new path the obstacle
becomes the white it becomes a new way
of doing things right in the case of
setbacks one way to like the
refrigerator issue one way to react
which comes kind of natural is as modern
cognitive behavioral therapies call it
catastrophizing oh my gosh the
refrigerator is not working what I'm
gonna do this is horrible this is a
catastrophe this is a problem bla bla
bla or you didn't look at the same exact
i and said that's an interesting
challenge so now I got a problem to
solve
let me see how I score on this challenge
and you start taking notes and saying
okay so here's how I reacted and here's
what I did and so on it's where you kind
of make it into a game essentially
wisdom was that a Marcus Aurelius ism
about was it called the equanimity game
was it about if you fall off a horse how
quickly can you get back on was that
Marcus Aurelius or am I making that up I
don't remember that in Marcus oh
definitely I've definitely just ascribed
something to Marcus Aurelius thingy the
other good obviously nothing to do with
almost certain I'm probably not
corrected but you see where that goes so
so it's a its exact same situation right
but now you choose to apply a different
frame and the frame a new frame that you
apply is actually productive as opposed
to being you know kind of undermining
yourself now whenever they say that
people say oh but so that means that
stores it was just a mind trick
and they say yeah you know what else is
a mind trick life everything everything
well that's this I mean you know for me
from a neuroscience perspective some
Harris has this beautiful quote where he
says in a practical sense everything
that we are seeing is a kind of a dream
except for the fact that we can control
what's happening in this dream well
watching app and everything manifests in
the mind right you know it doesn't you
only have that the bottom line if they
write this Stoics run the controllable
versus uncontrollable even further back
it would be what is inside of here right
of course um we have three more
exercises but my first question is do
you think that Seneca and Daniel
Kahneman would have been good friends
because I think that have been fantastic
you know like I can imagine them as in
crime fighting duo you know like like
going around the streets of Athens at
night just like throwing wisdom at
people doing loads of cognitive tricks I
think that mean I think that would it
that would have been something to see
alright so quickly we're doing pretty
pretty good timing so that's the three
exercise three exercises more honest one
of my favorite exercises that I do on an
occasional basis not our regular basis
is the sunrise meditation this is found
in Marcus Aurelius there is a bit in in
the meditations where it says that he
actually describes this this practice to
the pythagorean's which means that it
predates the story system it goes back
to the sixth century BC and it's it's a
very simple thing you just set up your
alarm make sure that you know you check
the weather forecast and so you know
that this either sunny or clear or quite
almost clear you set up your alarm clock
for about 45 minutes before sunrise
depending on how far you have to walk to
get there and then reach a location club
you grab your coffee and then get to a
location where you can see the sunrise
or as close to it as possible here in
New York it's next to impossible to see
the actual sunrise but you can see this
the Sun low enough you know buying some
level of bill
things on their aizen's good enough and
then you just stay there and wait sip
your coffee and and and focus your
attention and the fact that a star is
about to come over the horizon literally
of course don't do what Donald Trump
does don't look at the Sun straight
because that's a bad idea just just you
know look on the side or get some
special glasses if you really want to
look at it but the point is not to look
at that one place to experience the
event this is obviously a mundane event
it literally happens every day right but
we never pay attention to it because
very few people take the time to
actually you know set the alarm get up
early go to the place and then just stay
there for half an hour 45 minutes or
whatever it is and just think about
reflect about what's happening now why
would you want to do that it's a way to
reconnect with a broader
with the broader cosmos with reminding
yourself that you are actually part of a
gigantic whole of which to which you're
connected by a unbreak unbroken web of
cause and effect okay you may think that
the Sun is anything to do with you but
in fat literally the Sun is what keeps
you alive right if there were no Sun you
there would be no life on Earth as one
of my favorite scientists of all time
Carl Sagan used to say we're literally
Stardust all right all the elements that
make up our bodies literally we're
forged inside a supernova somewhere in
the universe and that's where we can
come from so qualities is beautiful and
in reckon next you're in a sense of you
know spiritual sense I don't want to use
the word spiritual in any kind of
mystical sense or not you know I don't I
don't think in those terms but it
transcends it's a sense of transcendence
there is very good empirical evidence
from modern psychology that a sense of
transcendence is one of the best things
long-term that that might make people
happy people that cultivate the sense of
trance and that's of course in some in
many cases this is literally believing
in a god right but that's not the only
way to feel transcendence I don't
believe you know in any particular
God and and that to me is a way to to do
it
incidentally you also get a very early
start in the morning
on the day so you get a lot of stuff
done that a good coffee first thing yeah
I love it that connection with nature
big big way is answer connected with and
there are other ways to do it I mean if
you're in a you know when I was in a
lived for several years in Tennessee I
would go whitewater canoeing for
instance so for the whole day I would be
just myself in a friend or two maybe in
the middle of nowhere surrounding just
by water and it's that's another way to
do it when I used to live in Italy you
know place small town north of Rome I
would actually call outside on purpose
on nice evening's and look at the Milky
Way because I could see a minute away
just stare at it right now I can't see
that the Milky Way from New York so so
that's not an option
only one thing if you're doing the
sunrise meditation don't cheat don't do
the sunset because the sense is not the
same this part of this how would you say
kind like a pilgrimage a small
pilgrimage that you need to make in the
is the price that you have to pay as
part of the correct I love it number
four number four Massimo number four all
right number four will have to say
the premeditation of an adversity is one
of those that those there's those start
techniques that I find particularly
useful although there is a couple
caveats so the terminal a team is
primitive Tate's premeditation malorum
which literally well not literally which
sorta translates to thinking about bad
[ __ ] happening is that malorum like
malady side thing yeah exactly as bad
things you know elbow room as a malady
as a bad thing so what one is it and you
want to do this well whenever you are
facing a situation that might not turn
out well for you okay like a pandemic
for instance yep right so what is the
meditation consist of well you take some
time to develop a in detail a scenario a
worst-case scenario and you ask yourself
you you actually visualize or otherwise
make a complete how you're going to
react
throughout this unfolding scenario right
so what is the worst thing that can
happen oh I'm gonna end up in the
hospital that's all more swing you
cannot go for swing of course there can
happen you're not gonna die but for that
one day's nothing you can do about it so
no let's go okay done but you end up in
the hospital you know in an emergency
unit or something like that that's the
worst thing the worst case scenario
right it's unlikely because for most we
need to remember that for most of us
this is actually an unlikely scenario
but nevertheless it's possible so the
notion is once again you might notice
that this is a recurring team you want
to make yourself prepared for that
search situation even though it's not
likely to happen but if it does happen
it's a tough one
okay that's not gonna be just enough to
say well what's under my control and
that's gonna be a tough one
so the priming the tatsu malorum means
that you're very carefully and
deliberately work through your worst
case scenario and the way in which
you're gonna react to that or say okay
scenario bit by bit
now there are different ways of doing it
the modern way to do it a popular modern
way to do it comes from cognitive
behavioral therapy this again there is
research here that shows that this does
work
and it's in the second form of a visual
meditation so you close your eyes and
then you you kind of slowly go through a
mental movie basically that that
carefully shows you to your mind's eye
what the situation is going how the
situation that I'm fault and how you're
going to react the problem with that
there's two problems with that number
one it's easy to slip into an emotional
state what are you doing that sort of
stuff
right you're supposed to do it in a
detached fashion you're supposed to
rationally think about what's happening
not emotionally so but the problem is
that when if you do it in as a as a
visual meditation a lot of people slip
into the emotional mode and that's bad
because then they actually instead of
solving you know helping yourself you
actually cause yourself anxiety and
that's not a good thing so you might
want to do it carefully if you think
feel it doesn't work for you then stop
doing it or doing doing it under the
supervision of a current behavioral
therapist who would actually help you to
go through the stages however there's
another problem with the to the
visualization exercise some people like
me I'm not good at visualization
exercises if I close my eyes and I start
thinking about something I fall asleep I
was like it goes off it's like nope
sorry that's not gonna do it or I get
distracted you know I go somewhere else
my mind so I have to constantly sort of
bring back that now that becomes like a
Zen meditation it's just too much work
so the way I do it is it's different
you can either write a letter to
yourself or to a friend without actually
having to send the letter you just write
it it's a branding essay or you write it
as a fictional story it's a short story
as if you were to publish a short story
on your blog or something like that
again you don't have to publish it it's
just for your own use right what's the
point there first of all the the simple
act of writing instead of thinking about
it already put some distance between you
and the situation it makes it more
detached is especially if you write in
the second or third person so if you if
you imagine and you run into a friend or
you're writing to somebody else or you
write a story in the third person you
know as a narrator that
some distance and this may sound like oh
you know like the small thing there's
actually a fairly good research shows
that it makes a huge difference
don't don't write that stuff in first
person because first person you get
emotional about it
um if you notice and if you go through
the meditations by Marcus Aurelius is
written in the second person he talks to
himself in the second person he never
says I do this I said always says you
did that and so yet he had this notion
already wait you know 2,000 years before
modern psychology that it's a better
thing if you actually detach yourself
from from this kind of stuff so the the
premeditation of adversity I think it's
very good because on the one hand if you
do it right it helps you exercise your
your fears and your anxieties because it
becomes a way to externally you know
objectively look at the situation
instead of worried about the situation
and it also prepares you for that
situation
should-should that kind of stuff
actually happens you know then then you
actually already have this certain
scenario worked out in your mind for how
you react so that was exercise number
four I guess four let's finish it on big
number five number five at the cost of
being of sounding morbid I'm gonna put
the meditation on death as one of my
favorite exercises um so here's the way
so the stories are big on death can lay
it on death yeah yeah let me let me show
you how so and in fact on that that one
is one of those bits where they actually
completely agree with the Epicureans
death should not be feared and the
reason you shouldn't be feared is
because as if you're curious says where
death is you are not and when you are
she is not meaning that you're not gonna
experience that that is literally by
definition the state of lack of
consciousness so if you're not gonna
don't worry about there's no such thing
as a you know Epicurus says don't listen
to the priests and the poets for trying
to scare you shitless about what happens
after after the did all they want to do
is to scare you or to control you don't
believe it Don don't be afraid because
there's really nothing to be afraid of
you might want to be concerned about the
before you get there
all right how do you get there but once
you get there there's nothing to worry
about now the Stoics had an interesting
positive take on death
sanika special the Seneca wrote a book
called on the shortness of life and the
story perspective there is that we ought
to live our life more or less as as if
we didn't know where we're actually
gonna be what was our last day what was
going to be that is if as you free and
no idea when we're gonna die turns out
we don't actually have any idea what
we're gonna die right we have
statistical expectations obviously no
I'm 56
I'm a white Caucasian male living in New
York so there's you know I can't look up
actuarial statistics and I can tell it
what my expectancy life expectancy is
but of course I could go downstairs and
do grocery shopping and being hit by a
car and that's it that's the end of
maximum it's not nothing else to do so
the point there is if you are aware of
the fact that you actually if you take
seriously because we all know it but you
don't think it seriously if we take
seriously the fact that you know what
this - well be my last day okay then all
sorts of things follow it's like so what
am I doing here what am i how am i
spending this day watching bad
television that seems like a bad idea
running and you know being a good book
when that sounds bad you know talking to
my friends yeah that's pretty good
watching you know I don't know playing a
video game that it's gonna make myself
mindless not probably not that good
there is an exercise in the book with
where Greg where we actually ask people
say look look list in number of tasks
and ask yourself number of things you do
during a particular day you know just
just take a day of your life and then
write down the kind of engineer and ask
yourself two things number one
is this meaningful to me and number two
would I be doing this on the last day of
my life
it really puts things in perspective a
very very right and so it turns out that
you can make a list of these things and
then of course the notion is to act on
that list so if it turns out for
instance that being on social media is
not the kind of thing you would do and
if you knew that this was the last day
of your life then probably that's the
kind of thing you want to do less I can
see how this would tie in with the
Epicureans
and they're a slightly hedonic approach
towards toward pleasure and right they
they put in perspective the silic says
basically this is a way to restructure
your priorities since your life is short
Bradley speaking certainly finite short
isn't is about of judges relatives you
know it's relative but Dilton is finite
you don't have an infinite amount of
time and so then the question is what is
your the best use of your time given
that it is in fact finite Seneca says
you know we are very concerned with we
when people ask us for money we keep
track and you know we give a loan to
some people even friends but we track
the money and we say no more concern you
am I gonna get it back and then people
ask us for our time and we just free you
give it as if we had an infinite amount
of it but we don't not only we don't
have any freedom out of it it cannot be
repaid you know the money can come back
the time doesn't come back so anytime
that that you know we make a decision
like for instance let me give you a
specific example of the conversation
we're having right now over the last
several weeks i I've got an
insignificant lis larger number of
requests for interviews and chats and
things like that right and I had to
start telling myself okay there's a
limited amount of time here in the week
you have to do these things so you need
to be picky you need to look into who do
the hosts I mean we're doing that as a
massive compliment ASIMO take it as a
company cuz that the way was meant
so that's the exercise I love it look
that is five very cool ways to implement
stoicism I I got I got so much more
stuff that I want to talk to you about
so I apologize to the other podcasters
who were trying to get you on the show
well I am just gonna completely
monopolize you and I'm gonna try and get
you back on as soon as I can it's been
rounds good amazing can you tell us that
you've got a number of different books
one of which is more practical than
another one which you tell us what what
books you've got people yeah live like
historic in the UK edition is the
practical one it's got these 52
exercises from which people can choose
you know sample and see how it works for
them how to be a stoic is my earlier
book and it's it's more comprehensive it
includes a historic theory a little bit
of history it also does have exercises
so it it has a small number I think it's
about 12 exercises at the end of the
book then people can do to start
practicing so those are the two things
that I would recommend terms of my books
there is a new one coming out in
September and it's called a field guide
to a happy life to be happy life and
it's basically a rewriting a 21st
century updating rewriting of the
picketers encouraging the enchiridion is
this classic texts of ancient stoicism
which has been rewritten and updated
several times the Christians used it
throughout the Middle Ages as a book of
Spiritual Exercises for instance and so
I decided that as a know March to a big
theatres in part this was time to do a
21st century edition alright so how this
is coming out in September that's
amazing that must be that must have been
a very fun very fun project for you to
work yes yes that's awesome well it's
selfishly again I don't have to wait
until September to get you one but let's
get you back on ready for that book and
then if we can get you on in between
brilliant look links to everything that
we've gone through will be in the show
notes below of course including
Massimo's twitter which you definitely
should go and check out as well any
questions comments or feedback just
hassle them online or give me a tweet or
do whatever it is that you want if
you're new here like share and subscribe
as always
for now Massimo it's been so good thank
you very much it's been a pleasure man
[Music]